I think virtual reality is a really
important emerging area of technology
but currently we're just using our eyes
and our ears as the basis for those
experiences and we've completely sort of
overlooked in a sense the body's largest
organ the skin is an interface into a
virtual computer driven reality is much
more challenging than one that's based
on audio or video so we've been working
on a thin flexible soft sheet that can
interface directly with the surface of
the skin and deliver very fine
resolution spatio-temporal patterns of
force to the surface of the skin a
virtual sense of touch so skin is a
fascinating you know biological system
in the sense it's bristling with sensors
of various types the skin forms the
basis of all our physical interactions
with the outside world and I think it
really establishes the deepest most
emotional types of contacts between
individuals and so I think it's rather
untapped interface and when you think
about VR AR technologies and I think
it'll define kind of the frontier of
opportunities and in the continued
development of those kinds of
technologies so it really forces you to
kind of reformulate electronics that be
more biocompatible or skin compatible so
the key unique features of the
technology or that sort of soft skin
compatible form factor the very tiny
miniaturized force actuator that we that
we've been able to develop a
corresponding set of wireless
electronics that allow these actuators
to be programmed in real time with a
very fast response speed and a wireless
way to deliver power to the device
that's really close it's an interesting
sensation but with appropriate control
of amplitude and frequency we can
reproduce a feeling that's very similar
to a natural human touch I think the
ultimate would be kind of a full-body
suit that would exist in the form of a
very thin spandex tights like
stretchable fabric we currently have
devices that embed up to 32 of these
individual force transducers these force
actuators the density of sensory
receptors and the skins much higher than
that so what we would like to do over
time is to scale the system we're pretty
excited about this new platform I think
this will represent a very powerful
starting point for the continued
development of this kind of skin
interface that I think will be important
for social interactions via computer
systems we think that they're going to
be powerful in clinical medicine for
guiding sort of refined rehabilitation
protocols in the context of stroke
survivors and amputees and others and
then for gaming and entertainment I
think there are lots of really exciting
possibilities in that space as well so
so it's really material science driving
new technology spawning a whole ray
array of application that we think are
going to be really exciting
you
[Music]